c'est un gars que quand tu balances une
araignée en fait il ya un chiffre qui
reste et y'a peut revenir après
s'entraîner c'est du fantasme a choqué
tous genres de chine ont survécu c'est
du vécu c'est pas la même chose je suis
derrière araignée contre la balance oui
quand elles placent balance à lens un
fil pour s'accrocher fausse pudeur base
puisse pas être vraiment c'est quoi
spider samedi en raison d'un évident que
j'ai raison tu peux pas me dire ce que
c'est qu'une araignée je connais tous
ouazzani je lis tout sur les araignées
je regarde tous sont les araignées je
suis un collègue jean toutu sont
associés je fantasme à rensou suis
incollable sur les agneaux à eux que
je peux même pas regardé non mais ça
c'est ça c'est mon cauchemar ça
pourquoi aucune coordination dagen
[Musique]
et vous vous avez peur de quoi moi j'ai
commencé par faire comme tout le monde
j'ai perdu mon nombre d'heures du loup
ou des monstres dans le placard c'est
par là on est donc en grandissant mais
en méga bonus et j'ai eu la voiture
impossible de me mettre à conduire
prendre le volant démarrer me donner
grosso modo l'impression de mourir pour
parvenir à faire ça ces quelques mètres
qui ne servent à rien j'ai mis des
années
cette peur-là viscérale invalidante
s'appelle une phobie du grec phobos et
froid voire un ange est là où les autres
ne voient pas mais entre la simple peur
et la vraie phobie ou est-ce que ça
bascule
à partir du moment où ça organise la vie
du sujet il me semble qu'on peut dire
qu'il faut be sans ça je parlerais
plutôt de peur ou de d'inquiétude ce qui
est pas pareil et
et je dirais aussi qu'il ya une grande
ambivalence dans la phobie c'est à dire
qu'il ya à la fois une une sorte de
haine ou de dégoût ou d'angoissé
vis-à-vis de l'objet et en même temps
une fascination une attirance voire
peut-être un amour alors pas pour
l'objet en tant que tel phobiques mais
pour ce qu'il représente dans la vie de
ce sujet
ma folie s'appelle la max ophüls
celle de l'eau aquaphobie l'astro folie
c'est celle du tonnerre
pas
en fait on peut avoir peur de tout et
s'entendre très souvent répété moi fait
rien du tout
[Musique]
car une phobie des autres c'est toujours
ridicule et ça donne même envie à
certains de taper là où ça fait très
très mal
je jure que je vous jure que je ne peux
pas je suis parvenu c'est pour s'offrir
au caire
vrai truc de comédienne
on reconnaîtrait donc la phobie au
comportement d'évitement qu'elle
provoque j'ai peur donc je fuis alors
c'est facile à dire comme ça mais dans
la vraie vie ça donne quoi bah ça donne
ça voilà je travaille chez ma belle
soeur il ya un ascenseur elle habite au
4e étage et il ya une porte la porte de
l'escalier
je voudrais prendre la porte de
l'escalier mais elle est fermée à clé
donc
là je l'appelle elle obligée de
descendre ouvrir la porte
et je monte à pied et de prendre
simplement l'ascenseur voilà
sur l'accueil
déjà là et on pourrait se dire qu'il est
moderne les râles comme truc c'est qu'il
a deux portes d'or ça ça m'angoisse par
exemple terriblement là je suis
je ne peux pas je peux pas m
je trouve que ça semble un cercueil
je m'appelle marie j'ai 41 ans
j'ai une une phobie qui est la
claustrophobie qui est
la peur de l'enfer moment et j'ai grosse
angoisse à l'idée de me retrouver
enfermé dans un endroit et évidemment ça
se traduit la majeure partie du temps
dans les ascenseurs quand on dit qu'on
est claustrophobe
c'est comme si quelqu'un dit j'ai un
rhume en ce moment à ouais ouais c'est
pas marrant mais bon y'a pas il ya enfin
il ya des gens qui posent des questions
qui s'y intéressent mais c'est pas j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas très pris au
sérieux ou comme quelque chose qui qui
qui prend la tête en fait la première
fois que j'ai vécu ça s'était conduite
et là c'est petit peut-être huit ans et
j'ai pris l'ascenseur dans la tour
eiffel et il y avait énormément de monde
j'étais petit entourée de beaucoup
d'adultes aussi et j'ai été j'ai pas
compris ce qui m'arrivait mais j'étais
complètement tétanisée angoissé et j'ai
l'impression que j'ai tout fait en fait
et
l'ascenseur ne s'est pas arrêtée
fonctionner mais l'idée d'être enfermé
et entouré de ses grandes personnes
autour de moi c'était
c'était assez atroce
broyer la main de ma grand mère avec qui
j'étais qu'est ce que vous aviez comme
symptôme à ce que vous incarnez vous
aviez coeur culturel est très vite et
puis hein comme si je me laisse envahir
par une
l'idée de que ça n'ait jamais se
réouvrir je voyais de penser voilà des
pensées qui imaginait qu ami jamie dimon
qui monte qui monte j'ai l'impression
que je suis on se vit 10 des séquelles
le dire d'accord enfermés ensemble y
voilà d'accord de quoi également comme
symptôme la gorge sèche ou une un peu
tremblements axe tremblements et amis
quasi imbattable qui tourne show un peu
chaud et d'être encore très très attendu
à tant de puissance musculaire surtout
les jambes le mollet avait exactement
pour faire simple la phobie c'est un peu
comme un thermostat déréglé l alerte
sont un danger extrême l'ain où il
n'existe pas ou peu et transforme la vie
en thriller quotidien un ascenseur
ensemble un cercueil des cafards à des
envahisseurs et un simple qu'on peut
provoquer la même terreur que disons un
tueur en série
moi je m'appelle françois thomazeau chez
58 ans
et je suis comme on dit j'ai fait
refaire phobique c'est à dire que j'ai
peur des plans
je voyage pas mal je fais pas mal de
trucs et je suis assez confronté de
temps en temps dans mon quotidien à
cette phobie qui est que
si un pont à proximité voire voir un
quai où une digue à quelque chose qui
est au dessus d'une étendue
d'eau pas forcément d'ailleurs puisque
j'aime pas non plus les viaducs au
dessus de la truck toutes ces petites
choses qui traverse et qui surplombe me
crée des problèmes d'adaptation
[Musique]
ah ah
quand je suis sur un point je n'ai pas
du tout peur que le pan s'écroule au
contraire au contraire au contraire
parce que si le bond est en bas et tombe
dans l'eau là j'ai plus peur tu vois ce
que veut dire ce que ce que ce que j'ai
ce dont j'ai peur c'est que c'est quand
le pont est en haut tu vois et si le
pont c'est cool c'est encore il ya plus
de ponts donc du coup cessé c'est
quelque part c'est mieux c'est ce qu'on
disait là on est sous le pont j'ai
beaucoup moins peur doit donc j'ai pas
peur du pont puisque je le regarde il
est derrière moi j'ai peur d'être j'ai
peur de traverser le pont c'est l'acte
de traverser le point d'être coincé par
le pont qui me fait peur
[Musique]
ok mais ça commence comme en sport à
l'entrée de la terrasse lava
montre ou avoir la preuve parce qu'elles
sont là une toile d'araignée là il ya
une toile d'araignée la suspecte non non
mais parce que tu ne vois pas mais il
est dans les mois je le vois quand on
regarde bien les voir mener voix il ya
plein de fils d'araignée ah ouais mais
oui on y voit rihanna la pagaille en
allah non tactile vois que tu veux faut
que tu bouges un peu comme ça regarde
toi là tu vois et n'a vraiment attroce
fait elle était là en fait s'il y en a
il y en a toujours une ici qua non mais
on est rendu là le fait de placer un fil
de fer non non c'est pas ça c'est pas
sûr mais je suis là là je l' ai vu je
veux et basse est le même mais de ce que
des gars leader tu viens demander avec
ton doigt aaa à aa
le supermarché de l'araignée ctt
arbustes non en fait nos supermarchés
ces insectes qu'elle mange si on met
leur pillage souffler ils vont au
supermarché là mais c'est là
c'est sur c'est quoi
mais c'est bon à regarder thaler le coup
s'en
aller non même assuré n'être en fait je
sais pas parce que quand tu vois des
toiles ça te fait tort aussi c'est juste
que de voir
du mal à toi ça veut dire qu'il va y
avoir un animal ou ça évidemment quand
il ya une tout ça veut dire kirin a
régné mais pardon stupre et les cheveux
dans une toile d'araignée sera mais
arrête m'arrête mais ça va pas mais
c'est fou tu es allé voir le astérix où
il y avait le suite à l'achat bas je
crois ou le premier premier c'est le 1er
août hurlait dans la salle parce qu'il y
avait les araignées la clavier il
s'enfonce dans un bain d'araignée voilà
alliés sortent par la bouche comme ça
toi je pense que c'est la première fois
où j'ai réalisé que tu pouvait déranger
une salle de 500 personnes à cause d'une
araignée mais ça a basculé cours et bien
justement c'est à force de voir des
faucheuses dans ma chambre et faucheuse
et des faucheuses et une faucheuse donc
je les dehors je voudrais pas
dehors des fois j'ai et c est un jour
j'ai commencé à en fait je sais pas
comment ça a brillé mais je sais qu'un
monde je me suis dit et si dans la nuit
elle rentre dans ma bouche
toutes les arènes higuain
ouais j'suis pas donc je demande à mes
petits copains étaient avec l âge en
fait quand tu es devenu vraiment
arachnophobes bas je pense 14 ans et en
fait rétrospectivement des années après
je me suis dit mais comment ça se fait
que je suis arrivé dans cet appartement
et je jouais avec les araignées quand je
suis reparti de cet appartement à champs
sur marne pour venir après à créteil
aller vivre à créteil pourquoi j'étais
je suis devenu phobique et je comprenais
pas et je me suis rappelé que à cette
période l'an 83 ma grand mère était
malade du cancer et elle est morte un an
après tu sais je me sens watch 96 les la
symbolique de l'araignée c'est pas en
rapport avec la mer avec la toile parce
que tu sais dernièrement j'ai découvert
une oeuvre d'art que tu dois connaître
c'est louise bourgeois
louise bourgeois je sais pas peut-être
que c'est de la psychologie de bazar et
c'est une gigantesque araignées et tu
sais comment elle applique cette oeuvre
d'art
maman il y a à un moment donné une
rencontre avec l'objet phobique qui va
devenir l'objet phobique qui ne
l'étaient pas avant parce qu'on a
peut-être aussi connu cet objet avant
sans avoir développé de phobies mais il
ya un moment cette rencontre avec cet
objet là va cristalliser et va générer
une phobie est à mon avis cette
rencontre avec l'objet
est à prendre dans un contexte de vie
d'histoire qui n'est pas forcément il
sait pas forcément passer quelque chose
d'incroyable pas il ya eu un grand
traumatisme cette année là et on a
déplacé sa sur la phobie enfin sur un
objet phobique mais il ya en tout cas
quelque chose qui a du mal à se
s'élaborer dans ce moment là et qui va à
mon avis se concentrer sur l'objet
phobique en gros faute de parvenir à
comprendre son ou ses angoisses on
mettrait tout dans la petite boîte
phobie pour limiter la peur à un seul
objet dit comme ça ça a l'air plutôt
pratique mais en réalité ça peut vite
donner l'impression peut devenir
franchement vous imaginez un clapier sur
trois étages à peu près de cet auteur
c'est comme ça tout bleu et je suis
arrivé comme ça j'ai fait ça et j'ai mis
mes impôts par acquis de conscience
voire j'aime bien grands coups de pied
et là j'ai c'est parti y en avait pour
tout ou alors ils n'avaient pas les
armes la verrière où s'est passé et j'ai
vu tous partis je sais pas il devrait y
en avoir une vingtaine un truc comme ça
ça a été une catastrophe je suis parti
dans l'année donc comme un malade je me
suis enfermé mais quand j'ai rouvert
mais je me suis enfermé j'ai fermé à clé
j'ai chopé mon téléphone j'ai appelé une
amie et je lui disais au téléphone mais
vient vite viens vite ils veulent me
bouffer ils sont en train de me regarder
il me regarde j'en vois un qui me
regarde et je sais même pas s'ils me
regarde et je crois qu'ils étaient tous
barrés et j'ai comme l'herbe était un
peu haute j'en avais vu un ou deux se
lever sur les pattes arrière je sais
même pas si c'est possible d'ailleurs si
je si je leur vision je sais pas s'ils
sont capables de le faire et donc
j'avais cette idée ils veulent me bouffe
ré île de nouvelle guinée calme toi mais
bien vie devient vite je vais mourir ils
veulent me bouffer il me regarde je me
disais mais le retour tu vas voir non je
veux pas sortir il me regarde
je m'appelle jean paul j'habite à côté
d'aix-en-provence et j'ai une phobie des
rats et dérange
l'image d'épinal on voit des femmes
montés sur des tabourets moi je ne vis
pas tous les jours ça ne faut pas
exagérer mais dès que je vois un truc
comme ça c'est c'est de cet ordre là le
le fait que ce soit que une phobie qui
est qui soit attribué généralement à des
femmes
à l'hystérie féminine on appeler ça
comme ça même si c'est faux je suis
désolé mais je
m'en fiche complètement ça ne me
concerne pas je je suis pas assez sexuée
on va dire ou pas ces matchs hills où je
sais pas pour vous pour avoir une vision
genre est pour moi la phobie à la phase
6 la peur est là pas de sexe langouët
cela pas de sexe je reconnais que
parfois il ya des gens qui se foutent de
ma gueule mais bon vin qui se fout de ma
gueule je m'en fous complètement c'est
pas grave
mais j'ai vraiment la sensation qu'on va
me bouffe les pieds que on va avoir
un truc qui me manque de femmes c'est
pas poussé par un truc qui montent
dessus quoi
d'une certaine manière j'ai peur de
mourir mangés par les rats
[Musique]
la phobie serait une peur de la mort qui
avance masqué alors qu'elle prenne la
forme d'un rat ou d'un avion finalement
peu importe car elle renvoie dans tous
les cas à l'instinct de survie
[Musique]
je m'appelle ninon j'ai 17 ans et j'ai
peur de l'avion
il y en a plusieurs sur qui représente
les morris et je sais que là j'ai appris
donc il y a même pas trop scène sa
lettre le prochain voyage que j'allais
faire donc qu'il va durer et presque 11
heures de vol et c'est un voyage que
j'appréhende énormément à l'île maurice
ma première un foot avec lapins en avion
c'était vers l'âge de 10-11 ans la
première fois où j'ai pris l'avion tout
seul avec avec nos petits frères est en
fait je me suis rendu compte que que
l'avion pouvait bas pouvait tomber
pouvait
pouvait ne pas mam nay où j'avais envie
d'amener d'être amené j'ai pas confiance
en l'avion en dans le pilote et dans
toute la main d'oeuvre et la maintenance
comme je peux ne pas avoir confiance
sont une terre tu peux te d'un coup se
fissurer ou ou des eaux qui peuvent
jaillir et en fait pour moi c'est c'est
assez similaire dans le sens où en fait
on peut pas prévoir et tout ce qu'on
peut pas prévoir ben ça fait peur au
départ j'étais psychologue je
travaillais sur l'anxiété les phobies la
prise en charge des attaques de panique
et en fait j'ai vu des patients qui
avaient peur de l'avion je me suis rendu
compte à quel point ça peut être
différent d'eux
et à quel point c'est spécifique aussi
pour cette peur d'avoir tout le côté
technique un peu de caumont l'avion
match les turbulences les orages les
pannes nous fera toute la partie gestion
du stress aussi pour arriver à muse et
raymond vos réactions donc san francisco
j'y suis allé en février c'était
impossible pour moi donc de cesse que de
passer la douane et donc j'ai passé une
heure et demie à accor commencé à
rentrer dans la file et à me dire non
non c'est impossible je repars puis
finalement la refaire quels sont les
symptômes on vole le
le stress les mains très très très moite
la
crispation avec
le siège et puis le fait que ouais
les pensées négatives viennent tout le
temps tout le temps et et puis quand
même là j'ai les mêmes web de voir way
l'argent ça me
on a commencé à m'appeler en fait au
micro parce que j'avais pris trop de
temps et donc il manquait plus que moi
pour rentrer dans l'avion et on m'a dit
dépêche toi parce que là il va partir
sans toit et donc moi tout seul dans le
hall
c'était terminal à l'autre l'opposé de
l'aéroport et donc je me suis retrouvé à
courir en fait pour aller prendre mon
avion ampleur complètement et et je sais
même plus quelle émotion
enfin était en moi puisque j'avais peur
et en même temps je courais pour prendre
un avion je voulais pas prendre
émotionnellement je me dis oh là là il
ya un problème et un temps j'ai eu ce
soir mais je sais que ben finalement
l'avion c'est pas dangereux donc on
arrive à reprendre le dessus sur sur les
émotions en se disant des choses qui
sont différentes donc c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille avec les techniques qui
s'appelle thérapies
cognitivo-comportementales ça permet à
la fois de modifier les pensées qu'on a
par rapport à une situation et en même
temps aussi comment je gère mon stress
différemment le fait de respirer vite
manger j'ai souvent très mal à la tête
puisque c'est vraiment soulagé au
revoilà les longs vols et puis après bah
c'était dur en effet de serre c'est
exactement comme si on était dans une
cage avec un lyon à l'époque nos
ancêtres tout simplement pour se bat
pour se protéger du danger ils avaient
besoin soit de fuir soit soit de pouvoir
se battre ce qui fait qu'en fait on va
tout de suite emballé le rythme
cardiaque donc on va hyperventiler on va
inspirer plus qui expirait ce qui fait
qu'en fait on monte en état de panique
et c'est pour ça que les gens
vous faire des attaques de panique des
fois parce qu'ils vont emballer trop
leur coeur ils vont oublier d'expirer
alors que l'expiration c'est le seul
système qui nous permet en fait de nous
détendre ce qui fait que ça mon serment
de st on n'arrive plus à se gérer alors
je n'ai pas peur que l'ascenseur tombe
sommes amassées et peshawar ça vous
l'avez paris ont pas du tout d'accord
moi c'est sortir je vais pas pouvoir
sortir quand je veux peut-être une perte
de contrôle
sûrement images à
saucisse à une perte de com de liberté
mesures et qu'ils contrôlaient voilà en
tout cas c'est ce que je propose est
l'angoissé de l'enfermement à ce point
comme je le vis aujourd'hui a été ça
s'est accru en vieillissant et je alors
pour le coup je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas pourquoi je ne sais pas
je sais pas quel a été le déclencheur
réel pour que ça prenne une
donc que ça prenne cette puissance
aujourd'hui je sache je n'arrive pas
encore à me l'expliquer et puis des
endroits où je dois m'en fermée à clé si
le verrou
voilà le public ben ça c'est même pas la
bonne at-elle pied ou le dos sacs à main
mais j'y vais pas c'est pas du tout ah
oui bah c'est pas possible donc là vous
faites est un évitement ouais tout ça de
surtout cet accord mais après je peux
avoir une angoisse
si vous m'enfermer dans une maison est
le très spacieuse et si je sais que je
peux pas sortir ni par les finales d'une
maison spacieuse je serai en stress et
besoin d'être un peu quand même j'ai
besoin de savoir que je suis libre de
mes mouvements et de pouvoir sortir
contrer
voilà j'ai un petit garçon 2
bientôt sept ans et je n'ai pas du tout
vu transmettre mon angoisse donc j'ai
dit que j'avais très peur tout
simplement que j'aimais pas être
enfermés dans des ascenseurs je suis
j'ai pas étendu ma peur sur
sur d'autres
d'autres endroits va dire après donc
il m'a juste dit que j'étais un peu toc
toc mais en rigolant que
comprenez pas pourquoi c'était un peu
ridicule pour lui et c'est pas plus mal
commencer non seulement je suis tout
seul dans l'espace avec du vide autour
de moi c'est à dire du vide devant du
vide derrière dû vite sur les côtés en
plus de la hauteur et en plus je suis
coincé entre deux murs qui me qui
m'oblige à a continué mon chemin et j'ai
aucun aucun échappatoire en fait et le
scc sac et qui est le plus qui fait que
le pont c'est pire encore que les autres
endroits dégagés c'est que non seulement
je suis je suis là sans repères au
milieu de dudu du vide quoi mais en plus
je suis canaliser entre deux regards des
ccd barreaux de prison ce truc là haut
voyez ce que je veux dire et donc toutes
ces sensations là font que j'ai un gros
malaise vis-à-vis de ça et que celui-là
il date de choix de la fin des années 60
et il a été content pas du tout conçu
pour les piétons et donc pour les gens
qui marchent à pied pour les pour nous
les humains il était conçu pour les
voitures et donc quand on est dessus non
seulement moi j'ai cet espace aucun
repère autour de moi j'ai cette marge
est là clervoy qui me fait apercevoir le
vide en dessous moi et en plus j'ai ce
passage permanent autour de moi de
d'éléments perturbateurs à mon équilibre
alors je sais qu'une théorie qui prétend
que ces pauses c'est possible que que
les phobies sont pratiques parce que
elles permettent de
focaliser tout un tas d'autres angoissé
de lait de leur trouver un objet donc
dans toutes tes angoisses plus profonde
qui peuvent être d'ordre je sais pas
affectif personnel sexuel ce que tu
voudras cultu l'air tue les tu l'aimés
là-dessus aude sur le sur le pont et ça
et ça permet de les ranger dans un coin
pourquoi pas ouais moi j'ai besoin de
pouvoir sortir quand je veux ses joueurs
d'avoir cette liberté de me dire je sors
quoi
ici à une pièce dans laquelle je suis
plus allé pendant un moment parce que là
parce que j'avais des bestiaux qui sont
plus j'ai croisé donc pendant un certain
temps je suis plus à l'est maintenant je
commence à aimer pour y aller je prends
des précautions je tape je vais chez les
rats là c'est chez les rats parce que je
suis oublier que comme chez les gens je
suis poli je tape et comme ça je sais
qu'ils vont partir et je les verrai pas
chez moi une chance de les voir donc là
je suis chez les rats
la pièce avait en bordel de ce que j'y
viens plus bas ou très peu même si je
commence à y revenir et en fait là si tu
me tapes rocher ici il ya le trou par
lequel il ya rentrée il y avait un tas
de bois alors c'est devenu chesaux 20
dans ma tête c'est devenu chez eux c'est
plus chez moi c'est le scheer
est ce que la phobie fait partie de mon
identité oui obligatoirement oui bah oui
surtout surtout si tu la cache pas que
mes même même sur la cache oui je pense
que ça fait partie de soi ça fait partie
de ce qu'ils te construis ou de
déconstruit ou de handicap parce que
c'est aussi un handicap
[Musique]
oui oui ça fait partie de moi oui il ya
une forme d'immaturité presque dans la
phobie quelque chose de d'une peur
extrêmement
infantile et mais
il ya aussi une honnêteté dans la phobie
c'est à dire que c'est à la fois une
névrose extrêmement immature on pourrait
dire mais qui à cette grande honnêteté
qui est que y'a pas tout ce vernis
justement culturel civilisationnel qui
se met par dessus est qui et qui fait
qu'on grandit et comprend des rôles
d'adultes plus ou moins incarné plus ou
moins comment dire
plus ou moins sincères qui peuvent être
parfois on a le cas de quasiment tous on
joue parfois être des adultes on est
adulte mais
jusqu'à quel point et jusqu'à quel point
on prend d'aider des postures dans la
phobie est quelque chose qui est presque
sans filtre
mais alors est-ce qu'on peut devenir
adulte en gardant ses peurs dans le fond
tant que la merkel est phobique des
chiens et sur cette rencontre avec
vladimir poutine en 2007 les versions
n'ont pas cessé d'évoluer
si poutine prétend avoir ignoré cette
fragilité de la chancelière allemande en
laissant son chien aller et venir dans
la pièce ce genre là d'autres y ont vu
au contraire une technique de
déstabilisation typique des jeux de
pouvoir
la seule certitude réside dans l'effroi
d'angela merkel
sa raideur la fixité de son regard et
son sourire figé
[Musique]
mon labrador à moi ça a longtemps était
cette voiture pas de traumatisme
d'accident j'ai juste grandi avec cette
phobie comme d'autres avec un bras en
moins
me mettre au volant provoqué une panique
absolue je disparaissais littéralement
sous le poids de mon angoisse
après mille passage de permis et autant
d'heures à être analysées hypnotisé
acupuncture is et j'ai fini par me
résoudre à affronter ma peur
vous vous voyez un volant un pare brise
d'une voiture en somme
moi personne normale et normatives
socialement inséré névrosé à ma juste
mesure j'y voyais disons une arme de
guerre
la voiture m'a longtemps renvoyée à ma
propre impuissance faisant de moi une
éternelle enfants
j'étais phobique de la conduite comme
angela merkel et des chiens l'origine dû
faire les symptômes sont les mêmes voire
un danger là où les autres n'en vois pas
et de ça est ce qu'on peut vraiment
guérir
[Musique]
vous respirez calmement
pour concentrer sur l'air qui rendent
quand vous inspirer et qui sort quand
vous expirez sur votre ventre qui se
gonflent qui se dégonfle au fur à mesure
de vos respiration quelle serait ma vie
si je n'étais pas claustrophobe
je me dis aujourd'hui on attend que le
straw flop que peut-être je maîtriserai
de cette phobie parce que je ne veux
plus que la peur ne maîtrisent mais je
veux maîtriser ma peur en fait c'est
vraiment ça qui qui qui pour moi est
important et
j'espère y arriver pour une vivre sans
sens
ce problème qui comme qui est un boulet
quoi le virtuel vous ça s'appelle une
thérapie alors là c'est avec le matériel
c'est de la thérapie virtuelle ou
thérapie en réalité virtuelle
donc c'est
plutôt un outil qu'une thérapie
qui explosent et principes qui est
utilisé principalement dans les
thérapies cognitives et comportementales
ou peut-être juste en thérapie virtuelle
mais c'est souvent un outil utilisé
puisque en thérapie cognitive et
comportementale on expose beaucoup les
patients alors faux billets ou l'anxiété
comme vous ou la scène anxiogène est
plutôt bien fait donc le beau
environnement vous ça va être des
espaces fermés notamment on va mettre le
casque ensemble ouais je vous aide voilà
pourquoi le mettre derrière vous là vous
avez une petite barrette est ce que vous
me permettez oui de m voilà comment ça
va la passer à la taille parfait donc
vous êtes arrivé devant la fenêtre
qu'est ce que vous voyez je vois la
campagne très
pâte l'accord sont des arbres
un peu tout un poteau électrique
d'accord la alors retourné vous que ce
que vous voyez dans la pièce comment
vous sentez alors vous tournez sur votre
siège
ça exactement bien je vois une seule une
pièce blanche et du carrelage une porte
en bois
au livre vous pouvez y aller vous êtes
libre de vos mouvements en virtuel voilà
je suis deux ans voilà donc la pièce est
pas très grande non plus mais pour
l'instant cela je veux rendre moins du
taux plein
alors bas comment vous êtes prêt si vous
êtes à combien sur 10 1 voilà ça va très
très hâte à 0 on va très très bien
parfait alors quand vous êtes prêtes
nous le dit alors c'est un symptôme qui
est je pense quand même assez
qui est quand même délicat à soigner
parce qu'effectivement il est très
bruyant il est très handicapant donc les
personnes ont très envie de se
débarrasser de la phobie
mais pour justement retrouver une vie
normale dit normal mais qu'est ce qu'une
vie normale parce que on est tous
confrontés à des conflits psychiques à
des malaises à des angoisses à des
questionnements et la phobie c'est juste
un questionnement qui hurlent et qui est
hurle fort donc effectivement il est
très handicapant il et il est très
pénible je pourrais sans doute me
soigner je vous ai choisi la stratégie
de l'évitement c'est à dire que c'est
pas c'est pas suffisamment déstabilisant
ou s'est pas suffisamment
moi dangereux ou
pour que je pense que j'ai besoin de
faire une thérapie c'est à dire que
j'aime pas les ponts j'évite les pompes
des gens qui m'intéresse c'est des gens
y ont des failles qui ont des
compromissions qui sont pas tout d'un
bloc j'ai remarqué assez souvent que les
gens confie mme psychanalyse et qui sont
allés au bout de la même manière que les
gens qui ont vu dieu ils emmerdent un
peu je les trouve je les trouve lis tu
vois j'ai des potes qu'on fait des
psychanalyses super bien réussi et alors
là ils sont ils sont totalement libérés
ils ont peur de rien ils sont souvent
assez fier assez sûrs d'eux mêmes
d'ailleurs il livrait je les aime pas
trop enfin je les aime parce que ça peut
être des potes mais ils ont tellement
perdu ce côté ambiguë toute cette
fragilité ou ses failles ou c ou c
compromission ou c'est quoi ce côté
humain finalement qui fait qui fait la
richesse de qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
raconté
tu vois nous les écrivains ou les
cinémas ceci si tout le monde avait fait
une psychanalyse quoi on vivrait dans un
monde lisse comme tout le monde ce
serait pareil ouais ça va wes une lip
nickel ta ta ta eu peur d'un truc
aujourd'hui non toi toi
qu'est-ce qu'on mettrait dans les films
ci avait pas d' assassin de 2-2 3-2
d'angoissé streamer tout le monde s'en
foutrait quoi donc donc moi j'ai pas des
réponses à tous et je suis ravi de
pouvoir la pense à tout ça me permet de
continuer à me poser des questions et
donc de vivre
un monde sans peur serait donc tout
lisse et tout plat peut-être mais bon
pour avant la chance d'en juger encore
faut-il être prêt à vivre une épreuve
sacrément costaud de celle de la
rencontre avec le monstre
moi ça serait
si tu les évite tu ne guérira pas la
confrontation est nécessaire l'évitement
n'est pas la bonne solution quand on est
phobique c'est absolument pas la bonne
solution je sais qu'il faut que tu sois
petit à petit confronté à la bête mais
moi je vais te poser quand même quelques
petites questions pour savoir un mot un
pays où tu en es parce que c'est quand
même important de démarrer pour
s'achever souvent les séances
individuelles de chacun réagit à sa
façon la morsure d'une araignée est ce
que tu l'a craint ou pas tu m'as pas
citer sa danse que tu m'as pas dans un
pays où il ya des araignées en avoir
déjà une idée fausse aussi que tu me
sors donc dans tous les pays du monde on
n'a pas à craindre les araignées ça
c'est des choses qui sont complètement
diffusées par les médias et réseaux et
ses amis gagnent et maintenant tu me dis
la mégalo singulier je te dise et les
mygales parce que là dedans lien 3000
espèces de megan la veuve noire c'est la
pire non toi par rapport à dangerosité
tu me sors que des choses fausses tu
peux me faire un dessin d'une araignée
schématique way l'antenne avant pour toi
c'est là et dans l'ariège sénat il lie à
ses yeux la
ces comme étant l'un des yeux deux
d'accord et des pattes à huit d'accord
tu les as pas si bien regarder ça parce
que là je sais pas ce que tu m'as fait
comme bestioles jeu pas d'ici non non
c'est pas ça c'est que tu me dis les
pâtes sont dans l'ariège et ses faux
n'est pas de son talent avant donc
toutes les pâtes sont en avant ah oui
c'est ça non crushpad articulé donc tu
m'as fait des yeux de hockey 4 ok 6 ok 8
la majorité du temps ils ont les yeux 8
yeux voilà elle a besoin de capturer ses
proies et d'être d'échapper à des
prédateurs elle a des yeux même vers
l'avant sur le vin le sur le côté vers
le haut vers l'arrière pas besoin de
tourner la tête pour voir tout
l'environnement et elle a une vision à
courte distance donc oui elle peut se
déplacer et ce n'était là jamais vers
nous en tant que l'espèce humaine elle
se déplace dans son environnement vers
des supports
tu n'es tu désolé de te dit tu n'es
qu'un support en fait pour elle
tron crs touraine samba combien je suis
se veut rester un support donné quel
support ça me dérange mais elle voit et
voit donc à courte distance donc pas
vision c'est beau mais la majorité des
araignées même les zones noires ne sont
pas mortels pour l'homme ça c'est faux
archi-faux ces sur les réseaux c'est
dans les films c'est pas la réalité du
monde néo rennais aucune araignée des
mortels pour l'homme le venin n'est pas
suffisamment puissant pour tuer un homme
tu as vu juste apporter une petite
peluche super
c'est juste pas parce qu'elle est très
douce
sans les pâtes alors au début je crois
que j'avais juste des petits pompons et
en fait on sent bien les grosses batman
il se trouve que ça c'est des petites
peluches que j'utilise aussi pour les
enfants parce qu'un peu moins d'accord
c'est intrigant planète le doigt dedans
et on peut mettre le doigt dedans mais
en plus elle est bien faite pour ça je
ne peux pas leur dis moi ce que tu
ressens là bas je n'aime pas et des
soyeuse elle a séparé la cp dit pas
lequel est en train de manger quelque
chose encore une fois que je t'ai dit
qu'il avait une bouche un tube digestif
et un anus elle fait des crottes liqin
puisqu'elle ne mange que du liquide
liquéfie tout ces points oui tu m'as dit
auto des bulles science j'aime bien
quand même regarder oui enfin si nous
aussi donc garder ce lien de fascination
en te disant qu'est ce qui pourrait me
plaire dans celle ci qu'est ce que je
pourrais mettre de positif dedans et
finalement des papes d'une araignée ou
réacteurs d'un avion le procédé est le
même abandonner ses craintes pour
comprendre l'objet de la peur en gros
réussir à regarder le dragon dans les
yeux
sinon je suis arnaud
je me présente j'ai fait donc je suis
pilote j'ai fait pendant une période de
20 ans de l'aviation d'affaires et puis
maintenant je me suis reconverti contre
autres dans des stages comme ça pour
aider les gens à vaincre leur peur de
l'avion
[Applaudissements]
il part comme ça bah c'est quoi c'est un
réacteur
tu prends un ballon de baudruche tulle
gonfle tu lâches ballon de baudruche y
pousse de l'air donc il parle ouais mais
c'est quoi la grise qu'en fait avec ce
rect
il n'y a pas de risque tu as beaucoup
d'air qui part très vite à l'arrière du
coup la réaction c'est que plus le
moteur va tourner vite plus on va
envoyer de l'air en arrière plus de
poids en arrière nantes le moteur va
avancer donc
sur les millions de vols qui se passe il
ya très rarement de problèmes avec les
réacteurs peuvent pas tomber comme ça
sinon il n'aurait pas fait ce métier up
suis moi on va l'être dans le simulateur
franchement
je suis je sais pas là parce que là ça
veut dire que tout l'argent il est sous
notre responsabilité
mais alors avant tu as quand même reçu
une formation oui c'est à dire que la
fin donc des parramatta respecté nous
aussi un des vitesses à respecter des
ongles à respecter des puissances à
respecter on les connaît bien on a des
routes à respecter et on sait que tout
fonctionne sinon nous ferait pas donc là
on va décoller tu va avancer les
manettes de puissance
voilà regard d'or
l'avion avance regarde droit devant
ça avance on entend la moteur qui pousse
toi caïman part légèrement à droite tu
mets un peu de pied à gauche choisit un
petit peu depuis la gauche va très bien
voilà
on continue à accélérer voilà bien sur
la piste comme ça un petit peu de pied à
droite
voilà
et là je te dis décollage tire sur le
manche il va chercher tes 15 degrés là
on est à 5 10 12 5 et 15 pouces un peu
sur le manche voit la balle et poussent
encore un tout petit peu toi qu'on est
un peu plus de 15 degrés est d'accord
avec moi oui nous voilà tous un petit
peu sur le manche rappelle décollage
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va rentrer les
roues de l'avion
passée cette mahatta je la tire et je la
monte les rouvre on se garde bien 15
degrés tiens un petit peu sur le banc
voilà et maintenant à faire un virage
par la droite alors vire à droite
incline un peu plus pour que l'avion
puisse tourner être un peu comme en vélo
tut inclinant vélo et ça tourne toutes
inclinées plus tu tournes bas nous c'est
pareil alors bien sûr un des limites si
on est trop incliné on alarme qui va
sonner
dans la bataille contre la phobie on
peut s'armer 2000 technique de la
psychothérapie à l'hypnose en passant
par le mdr ou la méditation alors
mobilisé ses dernières forces pour
affronter la bête ok mais pour gagner
quoi au final si la phobie n'est que la
partie émergée d'un iceberg angoisse
les extrapolations que je fais sur une
éventuelle guérison par kilo de
psychiatrie j'en sais rien je
me dis mais oui d'accord je vais me
soigner mais les rares aux besoins
existent et font que ça sert à rien
parce qu'ils seront toujours là mais
c'est vrai que je me dis oui de toute
façon les rails vont toujours être là ou
que la rue ont sauté dessus que j'en ai
peur aux gens des papes ont ils sont
toujours là donc ça nous donne une
occasion de ne rien faire une raison
pour ne pas vous faire soigner
donc là je ne ferme la porte avec les
chaleurs qui fait c'est normal il fait
très chaud mais la nuit en théorie si je
veux vraiment vivre peu plus
confortablement je devrai laisser cette
porte ouverte pour faire circuler tous
l'air frais de la nuit et dormir un peu
mieux sauf que je peux pas les faire
rentrer je peux pas les
ouais je peux pas les faire entrer donc
je ferme la porte au paquet rare entre
j'ai peur de rien j'ai un peu reculé des
jeunes qui rentrent j'en ai un peu rien
à même des sangliers mais je
ferme la porte la nuit pour même quand
il fait très chaud pour éviter que les
bestiaux ils viennent manger les pieds
dans ma chambre
j'ai jamais réfléchi à ce que pouvait
être une omission phobie parce que
on en a tous je crois plus ou moins
handicapante plus ou moins importantes
mais finalement ça me paraît difficile
de vivre sont promises child ou alors
c'est qu'on est je sais pas quoi qu'on
n'est plus lui-même
tcsa
si on n'a pas de problème est plus
humain
ça c'est qu'on veut dire qu'on est trop
par rapport à l'habitude qu'on l'a
demandé donc tu vois dès qu'on fait
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui sort un
peu la norme on a une arme une alerte
on a commencé à descendre tu peux sentir
l'autre un atterrissage
oui
hop
donc pour freiner faut bien tiré
alors là ils feraient leur a tout seul
tu vas voir
là on voit tous nos paramètres mois la
bonne vitesse dans la bonne distance à
la bonne hauteur la fedic saint-martin
cela autorise à l'atterrissage en
impeccable bonjour tu des goûts très
bien regarde c'est nickel moi je touche
à rien c'est super la ce que tu fais
tiens un petit peu sur le manche tire
tire tire doucement
on arrive à 200 pieds
freine tout seul avec les pieds tu dire
usa grand sur la piste on va doubler
rivers donc les deux managers en arrière
vas-y
et rivers à 0
voilà dit non
qu'est ce que t'en as pensé de ce stage
c'était super intéressant aimé nager
j'ai quand même peur parce que j'ai les
mains la
tenue c'était mais enfin j'étais
concentré
savait que enfin si pacy compliqué mais
c'est impressionnant valls à démystifier
un peu la chose est ce que tu te
sentirais en sécurité maintenant en tant
que passager avant
j'espère j'espère
m
non je pense que je me sentirais plus en
sécurité en tout cas
enfin parce que je sais ce qui se passe
et c'est ce qui me manquait donc
maintenant
j'aurai à plus de ça je sais ce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui maîtrise intellectuelle
sur le web plus de connaissances oui et
ça rassure ouais
là vous pouvez vous arrêter regardez sur
la droite est ce que oui les trois types
d'ascenseur il te fait pas bien donc
vous avez trois tailles 1 vous pouvez
choisir de vous mettre devant le grand
le moyen ou le petit peut-être le grand
pour démarrer par le congrès donc ce
sera le 1 c'est un ascenseur en verre
oui mais on peut si vous décidez de
rentrer dedans fermez le maître le
rendre opaque à lui d'être là il ya des
options on peut le rendre opaques ou
vitrée et on l'a fait rentrer
et on peut également
plus tard jouer sur la panne de
l'ascenseur où ça va jusqu'au 15e étage
ah oui d'accord quand même
vous pouvez donc là ce que je vous
propose c'est déjà de vous mettre devant
un des ascenseurs et de me dire comment
vous sentez rien que le fait d'être
devant un ascenseur bah ouais mais là
j'ai en fait j'ai c'est la lumière ça me
fait mal ça me fait mal aux yeux en fait
ce qu'ils aimeraient sait le faire une
pause ouest est excusez moi est ce que
les phobies se soigne oui bien sûr on
peut soigner les phobies alors
évidemment de sa dépendent le nombre
d'années la phobie voilà comment elle
s'est mise en place
ma thérapeute on m'a dit qu'il y avait
quand même énormément progressé en
quelques mois je suis moins phobique
déjà pu lui la dernière forme c'est donc
je continue à avoir des problèmes pour
prendre l'ascenseur mais je le vis très
différemment ce qui est très agréable
parce que je sais que je vais régler cet
aspect là et que un jour je ferai comme
tout le monde je prendre l ascenseur
même pour un étage peut-être qu'eux
mêmes je serai avec jouissance ou
d'appuyer sur le bouton 1
[Musique]
ce à accepter aussi d'avoir des failles
en fait d'avoir une famille je pense
être tendre avec soi-même pour
l'accepter et puis régler ce problème
tout simplement
la vie sans flou miss l'objectif je sais
que ça se traite donc il n'y a aucune
raison que je n'y arrive pas et ça
ressemble à un droit à une légèreté son
nom en fait dire que
c'est quelque chose une
un encombrement en moins dans la tête et
ça c'est c'est hyper riches en fait
c'est enfin un truc en moins c'est cool
alors est ce que tu peux toucher st
non non c'est une patte ça
ouais c'est bon j'ai touché non t'as pas
toucher pour que ça se regarde fait
comme si
c'est do we agréable oui ça va tu
m'avais touché une des pâtes que tu as
les prix de la meilleure exactement ça
fait des petits morceaux et comme je
sais que cela me voilà déjà dans mon
imaginaire c'est
peter l enlever elle avait enlevé ses
vêtements c'est ça ouais c'est très bien
en fait maintenant tu veux maintenant tu
le visualise mieux qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une niche est ce juste ça ouais
mosquée pas que c'était
carton prévoyant tu dois être là bas
sans souci je te faire en fonction de ce
que tu me dire
voilà
encore une fois dit toi j'aime pas
mais
them more time out elle est morte ok
c'est bon c'est bon non mais tu une
approche pas plus un cheese on habite à
7,1 c'est parce que tu vas faire pour
essayer de la connaître un peu mieux
éventuellement tu t'engages à la loupe
non donc elle est en train de bouger ses
pattes pourquoi essaye de maintenant de
rentrer dans le monde que j'étais décrit
encore une fois incarne cette curiosité
oui je la regarde la grille corps sans
associer couple et fils entre eux
l'envoi ce ya aucune angoisse à avoir
encore une fois rationalise vallée sur
ta main quand même elle est sur ma main
je suis un support je suis un support je
suis rien
je peux la mettre dans le terreau riolo
oui j'aimerais bien que jamais de nous
en fait tu ferais pas ça dans le truc
que sur tapis voilà tu as bien fait rien
oui tout à fait
ouais quand même tu avais ça sur la main
de loin ça faisait plus petits
vieux
[Musique]
depuis quatre mois j'ai pris deux vols
et le premier s'est particulièrement
bien passé j'ai ressenti actionnaires
aucun aucun truc que je ressentais avant
et même si j'avais quelques petites
enfin sensations parfois quand même au
décollage essentiellement mais en fait
j'étais super contente à la fin parce
que je me suis dit wow
c'est parti presque enfin si ça a rien à
voir avec avec avant et et ouais c'était
c'est super agréable en fait de sentir
comme ça
[Musique]
mes parents étaient assez surpris la
dernière fois que ça ait pris l'avion
avec moi j'avais des sueurs froides et c
est là vraiment il était impressionné
mon père et il me regardait pas peur là
et j'y fais pas la savane ont alors je
sais pas si je me sens vraiment
différente mais j'étais assez fier de
moi de pouvoir aller au delà de cette
étape et cette peur
avant quand je regardais des avions de
décoller moi je n'étais pas très très
agréable j'avais déjà au moins des
grandes transpiration et quand j'en vois
un décoller bas ça ne peut rien je suis
contente bon j'espère juste qu'ils
arriveront à bon port mais à part ça non
il ya pourrait encore
[Musique]
qui on est quand on n'est plus faux big
ben on est je dirais la même personne
mais qui va
qui va trouver
peut-être des symptômes ou des mois dans
mardan dans ma façon de parler symptômes
c'est pas forcément négatif quoi c'est
pas forcément quelque chose de en tout
cas une autre façon d'être au monde qui
va être peut-être un tout petit peu plus
agréable je dirais même peut-être un peu
plus vivante parce que parfois la phobie
s'amortit fille parce qu'on est
paralysée pour x ou y raison mais c'est
dire est que dans la phobie aussi il ya
aussi sur ce rapport vraiment très
étroits entre le sujet et son objet
phobique comme si c'était une relation
auquel les autres n'étaient pas invités
quelque chose qui vraiment est collé du
sujet à l'objet et à partir du moment où
ce lien se distend un peu et devient
plus plus cool
ça ça ouvre des perspectives aussi juste
de de lien au monde
la phobie est une ennemie intime elle
vous accompagne partout cole chacun de
vos gestes et pèse sur chacune de vos
décisions comme le ferait votre
meilleure copine en or de son emprise on
en fait quoi de cette liberté tout neuf
quand tu te confronte à ta phobie de
temps en temps ça te prend étudie
maintenant j'en ai marre jv dont tu
respirer un grand coup et est têtu et
têtu traverse un pont c'est un sentiment
de victoire incroyable c'est un signe
c'est vrai c'est un succès phénoménal
c'est comme s'ils avaient gagné les
olympiques katia et après s'être pendant
trois jours tu es super fière de toi
quoi tu te vois tu te situes fait ça au
champagne foyers non non c'est une vraie
satisfaction donc donc ça veut dire que
tu ressens quand même ça comme un échec
tu vois où il ya quelques parents la
phobie un truc qui te met à nu fac et
c'est justement parce qu'on a tous des
failles conviant société si on était des
êtres pur et parfait moi je vais j'ai
besoin et pas besoin de vous les gars je
me promène tout seul sur les ponts et
j'emmerde tout le monde
donc cesser ouais c'est la mosaïque des
failles des uns et des autres qui fait
que con et qu'on est bien ensemble
pièces de cette mosaïque les phobies et
les manières d'y faire face son propre à
chacun ninon prend désormais l'avion
sans trembler et elle a adoré l'île
maurice
marie poursuit sa thérapie à new york
elle a pris l'ascenseur jusqu'au sommet
d'un empire state building 102 étages a
priori elle devrait pouvoir s'épargner
d'escalier quand elle va chez sa belle
soeur il y à peu sandrine un croisé une
araignée chez elle elle dit qu'elle a
presque trouvais jolie mais qu'elle n'a
pas eu envie d'en faire une copine pour
autant
jean-paul lui continue à frapper pour
entrer chez les rats de toute façon
c'est incontestable ils seront toujours
là
quant à moi à force de combats avec ma
peur et de discussions sur le divan je
suis devenu une ex comiques comme on
devient ex toxico ou alcoolique
abstinent en sécurité mais toujours
précaire les phobies sont des invités
indésirables
elles envahissent votre salon et vous
force à vivre grenier on peut s'y
trouver plutôt pas mal ou batailler pour
retrouver le plein espace c'est le choix
de chacun ni pour qu'ils acceptent le
combat contre ses démons si habile à
garder leur mystère c'est un monde plus
riche plus réel et peut-être plus
aimable qui s'ouvre sans peur érigé en
défense entre les autres et nous
parmi eux avec eux
[Musique]